excusez-moi monsieur rayet
tu finis de décoller chewing-gum de
transat ou quoi
j'ai l'impression d'arriver à rien tu
retournes toujours sur tes pieds frérot
tu es Jamie
là bas nous trouver du taf et tu reviens
avec un pauvre burger je crois pas que
ce soit un burger
c'est quoi ce machin
comment tu as réussi à faire ça je crois
qu'il m'aime bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu essayes de tu vois tes yeux
c'est quoi ça c'est toi trésor
[Musique]
je suis dans l'espace atmosphérique
activée
on l'appelle le scarabée c'est une sorte
d'arme de destruction massive il est
conçu pour protéger son ôte à tout prix
parfois il fera ce que tu lui demandais
d'autres fois non
je crois que j'ai coupé un bus en dehors
le scarabée t'as choisi
mais il est à moi
l'amour que tu portes à ta famille
te rend faible
[Musique]
l'univers t'as fait un cadeau et c'est à
toi de décider ce que tu veux en faire
tout ce que tu peux imaginer
je peux le créer
et c'est parti
excellent choix